let's go one by one by one Larry Page
and Sergey grin Sergey Brin based on the
research you've done what what have you
learned about those guys from Google
okay so as far as Google as a company
goes from the very beginning of that
company they took um National Security
State money specifically CIA money and
throughout their existence as a company
like we know from the Edward Snowden
documents uh collaborated very openly
with the NSA and other national security
agencies uh to the you know and sharing
data in ways that they were not you know
public about with their their customers
and users and of course Google dominates
search so they have a huge
um
role in the type of information people
access when they look for something
those first results what results are
first you know Google has a lot of power
and to take it back to WikiLeaks for a
second um if you remember back um I
believe Julian Assange wrote a book
called when Google met Wikileaks
basically talking about how he his
experience with that uh led him to
believe that Google was essentially
operating as an intelligence agency in
connection with the Hillary Clinton run
State Department
so and you know I think jigsaw at the
time
um which was part of alphabet had these
weird connections
um with you know things going on in the
Arab Spring and other geopolitical
developments where Google was alleged to
have played an outside role
um so it's important to keep in mind
those aspects of Google
um but you know as far as the connection
specific connection to Epstein goes uh
Larry Page I'm not necessarily familiar
with anything but before the subpoena it
was known that Sergey Brin was going to
the townhouse with Epstein in the early
2000s he was yeah and I think at least
one of those meetings Mort Zuckerman
who's listed on that subpoena list as
well was present that these were some
regular visitors to to his townhouse in
the early 2000s and it's possible as
well that you know this Edge Foundation
thing and again I'm not trying to say
Edge is a pretty big thing not everyone
that was part of edge was tied up with
Epstein but I think it's pretty clear
from the finances alone that Epstein use
that billionaire dinner and his big role
as the main fun for a long time of Edge
and being very close to Brockman to get
access to these big tech people you have
to keep in mind too that after Epstein
was busted for sex trafficking the first
time he tried to Rebrand as a big time
Tech investor
specifically and his big company that he
was trying to make out of the Virgin
Islands which I think he made in like
2012 was called Southern trust and he
framed it as being a biomedical and
financial Google he it was it was
described by the New York Times as a DNA
data mining firm so he's trying to get
in all these these spaces that also
Google and a lot of these other big tech
companies are also trying to get to in
relatively the same period of time
because 2012 is like 10 years ago you
know a lot of people are talking about
AI now and all of this stuff but Epstein
was trying to sort of corner this market
for the AI market for big Pharma and for
uh major investment Banks back during
that time and actually in these Wall
Street Journal
um reports that have come out recently
it mentioned that the Edmund de Ross
child group Aryan de Ross child named in
in those documents had entered into an
agreement with Southern trust I think
around seven million dollars that they
had contracted this AI Financial
algorithm uh company that Epstein was
making in the USVI
um so you know again the financial
services thing with Epstein is very
underexplored by mainstream media and
what you refer to there about the public
perception of oh you have your picture
with Epstein sure you're a pedo I would
blame all of that on mainstream media
because mainstream media is only
interested in talking about Jeffrey
Epstein's sex trafficking activities
from 2000 to 2006 nothing before and
essentially nothing happened what do you
think I think it's uh to protect a lot
of powerful people that engaged in
financial criminality with them and also
um
also uh people like Bill Gates and Bill
Clinton
as well because a lot of that uh you
know their ties uh for example with
Gates that goes back to the 1990s
mainstream media says it was 2011 and
the reason I think they say that is to
Gates didn't have any role in Microsoft
at that time if you look back before
then there's a lot of gates and Maxwell
Family Ties to Microsoft and other
Microsoft Executives Linda Stone Nathan
mervold documented Epstein ties with
them back in the late 90s so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
foreign